[Musik]
darf ich vorstellen meine frau gegründet
wir haben es mit collect zu tun eine
künstlerbiografie über die
schriftstellerin colette die anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts mit ihren
romanen in paris furore machte ich
möchte an allem teilhaben und nicht wie
eine kleine haus vorbehandelt collette
war eine ganz spannende person sie bei
mädchen vom land das einen literatur
unter premier geheiratet hat wird an
allem teilhaben versprach eine menge
ghostwriter für sich schreiben lassen
und unter dem namen willi wurden dann
diese romane und fühlt etc
wir haben geschichten von willi musik
rezensionen von willi jetzt kommt willi
sie ist darum wer wird diesen roman
schreiben sie ist dann auch der
eingestiegen hat romane geschrieben die
wurden dann natürlich nicht unter ihrem
namen veröffentlicht
was glaubst du stimmt nicht und darüber
kommt es dann zum zerwürfnis wie es
diesen ehemann weißt du endlich haben
wir erfolg und dann kommen von die
andeutung ich wäre sich der autor das
ist nicht wahr und sie beginnt dann auch
gleichgeschlechtliche beziehungen was er
wiederum fördert und also ist ein großer
tumult ein großes durcheinander wenn sie
ihre augen aufschlagen ist es als würden
sie mir meine kleider ausziehen sie
nicht weg sie mich an sie mich an
wichtig ansehen
dieser film ist besser als man es
vermuten könnte viel besser sogar der
film schafft es die komplexität dieser
figur sehr gut zu zeigen und auch die
komplexität der männlichen figuren die
sie umgeben und das ist für einen film
der sich und dezidiert als sehr
feministisch präsentiert auch eine
interessante wendung eindruck dass heute
grabenring eindruck des abends ich bin
angeekelt die leute die mit sachen
geworfen haben sind feiglinge und ich
bekam nur kein stuhl ins gesicht weil
ich ausweichen konnten gut befinden
macht
collette dass die figuren nicht
schwarz-weiß sind zum beispiel ihr
ehemann wird schon nicht als der
ausbeuter gezeichnet sondern man sieht
sehr klar dass ohne ihn sie niemals
angefangen in herne ist kloten
ich lebe in montigny
hier werde ich aller voraussicht nach
nicht sterben das ist gut
offenbar wurde wir die zwei weise von
ihrer schulzeit inspiriert ja ich denke
eine kleinigkeit habe ich beigetragen
keira knightley spielt die hauptrolle
sie spielt das sehr gut sie schafft es
problemlos das junge mädchen zu spielen
stark sich unsicher und dann die dame
von welt oder von halbwelt zu deko
lettern wird scheinbar ist kledy mal
gegenwärtig in diesen tagen ja es gab
sogar eine klo die mörderin in marseille
sie schlitzten ihrem mann die kehle auf
schön für sie und dominic west deren
ehemann spielt ist ein absoluter
gelangen
mein plan ist dass kloten zum
berühmtesten mädchen frankreichs zu
machen
ihr buch wird die welt verändern
sag mir wie viele menschen in diesem
park lesen gerade studien in paris
eigentlich ist er derjenige der alle
anderen an die wand spielt als ein total
überschäumende typ der ein schurke ist
aber auch ein großer liegender ein
großer kunstliebhaber und ein großer
geschäftsmann aber letztlich dann halt
diese frau auch verliert weil er ja
nicht gerechnet all den jungen mädchen
eine stimme gegeben wie nie hat das sie
haben das wie sollten sich dazu bekennen
[Musik]
ich bin die ware kloten
ich werde damit weitermachen weil ich es
möchte
also alle die sich dafür interessieren
wie kunst entstehen kann was es alles
braucht damit etwas neues passiert und
wie aufregend das leben auch schon in
der zeit die wir so als total rigide
noch in erinnerung haben oder uns
vorstellen war für diesen film sehr gut
geeignet die hand die die feder hält
schreibt geschichte